the mainstream media are having a field
day with the saucy anti-trump book
quotes and president Trump's giving
Steve Bannon the Rosie O'Donnell
smackdown we will analyze the claims and
separate fact from fiction
then flex talks Austin Fletcher and
Jacob berry will join the panel of
deplorable z-- to discuss Jeff Sessions
is crackdown on pot the OL Haitian
oregano and how the Virginia House of
Delegates highlights the moral error of
never Trump finally the mailbag
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
this entire show today is gonna be page
six basically it's just saucy claims and
pot and all this sort of stuff but
before we can get to any of that we have
to talk about something that I am very
excited about now you know I always say
they never pay me here they don't give
me any money to show up they do
occasionally I'll get a freebie from one
of the advertisers and this is a really
good one this is Bolin Branch sheets so
it is very important if you're like me
and you spend 14 to 18 hours a day
sleeping you you're gonna want to make
sure that you're on good sheets and look
I'm I'm a cheapskate sometimes I'll go
and I'll buy the worst sheets that you
can find the cheapest sheets at the
local store or on the internet and they
will feel like sandpaper
they will chafe my skin they're not
comfortable at all but if even if you're
not like me you still probably spend
anywhere from six to eight hours a night
on your sheets you should treat yourself
we live in decadent times treat yourself
to nice sheets and bedding you will not
regret it I am Telling You and now some
some of these sheets if you want really
really high quality sheets they can cost
a kid you're not a thousand dollars and
then they're worth it by the way but
Boland branch has something special you
can buy directly from them so you're
essentially paying wholesale prices so
you're getting you know these luxury
sheets could be a thousand dollars bull
and branch sheets are only a couple
hundred bucks for just the exact same
high quality everything Bolan branch
makes from bedding to blankets is made
from pure 100% work anak cotton this
means that they start out supersoft they
get even softer over time unlike my
sandpaper sheets where they start out
really crinkly and then I get even
softer over time you don't want that you
want the sheets to get better as you use
them so everyone who tries Boleyn branch
loves them I can tell you this for sure
that's why they have thousands of
five-star reviews
Forbes The Wall Street Journal Fast
Company they're all talking about Boleyn
branch three u.s. presidents sleep on
Boland branch sheets three u.s.
presidents and one presidential endorsed
best-selling author of a completely
blank book all I don't know what I think
one group of that is more impressive
than the other they all sleep on Boland
branch the shipping is free you can try
them for 30 nights if you don't love
them send them back for a refund you
will not want to send them back I'm tell
there's no risk there's no reason not to
give them a try really just give them a
try it's completely free to try them out
and you are gonna be hooked I promise
you to get started right now my
listeners get $50 off your first set of
sheets that goes a long way toward
getting a set of these really nice
sheets it's got to be your first set so
if you're hoarding bowling brand sheets
sorry you're not gonna get the discount
but for the rest of you you're gonna get
it go to Boland branch calm vol L at
branch B ra n CH calm promo code Michael
that's Boleyn branch calm today for $50
off your first set of sheets bol L and
branch calm from O code Michael mi CH AE
L really really great company great
product go check it out okay let's get
right into all of the sauciness now that
I did roll out of bed off my bowl and
bran sheets and saw all of the crazy
scintillating headlines today let's go
through the claims we've been talking
about this book all day there's a hot
book that's gonna come out over Donald
Trump and the White House that's saying
he's just awful everything's chaos Steve
ban and got smacked down for this let's
go through and see which claims are
credible which you're not
here they are Joker all compiled a great
list of the daily wire a lot of other
authors have to number one he's not only
crazy he's stupid billionaire and Trump
confidant Thomas Brock jr. told a friend
berrak Barack Barack you know said this
is totally false
wolf never ran the quote by him to ask
if it was accurate he also said it's
clear to anyone who knows me that those
aren't my words and inconsistent with
anything I've ever said what do we think
about this I guess he could have said it
if he did say it he wouldn't he
certainly would deny it at this point
that said what motivation does he have
to say it what motivation does he have
to say it just some nobody
lefty reporter or writer I don't see the
motivation there I'm skeptical that he
said it I'm skeptical that the writer
Michael Wolfe heard this in an
incredible way number two Melania was in
tears and not of joy on election night
they didn't want to win the White House
they just didn't want to be this is one
he wrote a the the
author of this book wrote a piece in the
New York magazine said Trump didn't
really want to be President I it's this
is hard to believe guys he's been
talking about being president for 30
years he has been encouraged to run for
30 years he flirted with it in the year
2000 and he almost ran for the Reform
Party nomination he seriously considered
it in 2012 he's been talking about
issues of American policy both domestic
and international for decades even
during the Reagan administration you
took out a big ad in the New York Times
to question an aspect of the Reagan
foreign policy I just don't believe it
people do people don't know what it
takes to run for even dog catcher or
Congress or governor much less president
the United States if you don't want it
you're not going to do it he wanted to
win that's total nonsense number three
when Roger Ailes suggested Trump tap
former House Speaker John Boehner for
White House chief of staff he said who's
that don't you get it cuz Trump's such a
dummy he didn't know who the Speaker of
the House was right
ridiculous yet we know yeah Donald Trump
tweeted about John Boehner in 2013 he
said quote Speaker John Boehner who I
like should never have agreed to raise
taxes because the Republicans got
absolutely nothing for it he sent out
another tweet Danxia or rather Don jr.
agrees with that but here's another
tweet from Donald Trump about John
Boehner in 2015 from tweeted whacky
Glenn Beck who always seems to be crying
worse than Boehner speaks badly of me
only because I refused to do his show a
real nutjob you can't have it both ways
you can't have it and say that Donald
Donald Trump ever does is watch cable
news he's glued to Fox News morning noon
and night but he's never heard of any of
the things that are talked about there
sorry guys you have to choose a line of
ridiculous attack and Michael wolf is
trying to have it both ways it just
isn't true another quote from there is
working with the president was like
trying to figure out what a child wants
this was attributed to Katie Walsh White
House staffer she denies having said it
he's done what he said he would do
that's that's what has shocked so many
people you know it's sort of surprised
me as well but he has done it so trying
to figure out what he wants he's been
saying what he wants for 30 years this
is one of the crazy aspects of trumpism
they say he's playing for DHS he isn't
for DJ's he said he would nominate
originalist he has he said he would cut
regulations he has he said that he would
lower taxes he has he's just doing what
he said he would do and this is
confusing a lot of people certainly not
like working for a child
number five wolf reports that six weeks
into office Donald Trump's still had not
determined what the new administration's
top priorities would be and said that
operations in the West Wing were chaotic
ditto on the last point exactly did on
the last point we we know what the
agenda has been he said it during the
campaign and he's fulfilled it now what
about Michael wolf we know that this guy
has very little credibility he this
isn't his first book he's been around
for a while he admitted to lying in his
first book burn rate which was about his
time in the early days as an internet
entrepreneur you know the dodgiest
profession imaginable the dodgiest
profession until like bitcoin broker or
something so what are some of those
allegations he wrote in that book quote
how many fairly grievous lies have I
told how many moral lapses had I
committed
how many ethical breaches had I fallen
into like any other financial conniver I
was in short-term mode so this is a guy
who has no credibility is admitting he
has no credibility as a matter of
honesty he's saying that he's a liar his
business collapsed in 1997 surprise
surprise is for anyone familiar with the
dot-com bubble that book came under
siege he took very few notes yet he
recounted long conversations verbatim
Judith Regan a classmate of wolfs at
Vassar disputed every single thing that
he wrote about her in that book and said
that she hadn't talked to him in 30
years and he admitted that he hadn't
talked to her in 30 years
Andrew Sullivan the political columnist
accused wolf of fabricating whole quotes
of his in 2001 in total 13 subjects of
burn rate said that wolf invented quotes
from them whole cloth so the guy has no
credibility the New York New Republic's
Michele Caudill wrote about him quote
much to the annoyance of wolfs critics
the scenes and his columns aren't
recreated so much as created springing
from wolf's imagination rather than from
actual knowledge of events even Woolf
acknowledges that conventional reporting
isn't his bag he's a droid and making
the reader think that he has spent hours
and days with his
object when in fact he may have spent no
time at all but of course none of that
will deter the mainstream media will it
absolutely not they are having a field
day with all of this that's because they
are less credible than wolf Esquire says
if Michael Wolf's access to Trump
surprises you then you don't know
Michael wolf but New York magazine ran
Donald Trump didn't want to be President
ha ha
Vanity Fair wrote how Michael Wolf's
stuck a shiv in Donald Trump Cosmo 5
bombshell revelations about Donald and
Melania lationship from new
behind-the-scenes book okay all
ridiculous and by the way when Ed Klein
wrote that book about the Clinton or
about Barack Obama rather called amateur
did we see bombshell bombshell bombshell
and all of those news outlets absolutely
not
we saw people calling his credibility
into question calling the quotes into
question but not so here the story is
just too good now what about the banning
quotes what does this mean about all of
the banning quotes wolf alleges the ban
and said quote Donald Jr is a traitor
these treasonous that he's going to be
cracked like an egg on national TV that
the Russia meeting was treasonous that
Breitbart is not a legitimate news
source a son-in-law Jared Kushner is
greasy and that they are sitting on a
beach trying to stop a category 5 now
Bannon was apparently the guy who
allowed wolf into the White House his
access appears to have ended Wolf's
access when John Kelly took charge their
reports came out as early as August the
Trump blamed Bannon for the leaks David
Moore tosco a conservative writer wrote
in case it's not clear to everyone by
now Steve Bannon was the single biggest
leaker in the White House in the West
Wing until his departure Don jr. agrees
Donald Jr wrote Steve had the honor of
working in the White House and serving
the country unfortunately he squandered
that privilege and turned that
opportunity into a nightmare of
backstabbing harassing leaking lying and
undermining the president Steve is not a
strategy strategist he's an opportunist
plus most damning of all Trump smacked
him down yesterday
now Trump's natural reflex is to call BS
on the mainstream media to call fake
news for some reason though he seems to
think Bannon really talked to this guy
doesn't mean the quotes are truthful
Bannon didn't even join the campaign
until two months after the meeting he
allegedly
treasonous took place but Trump seems to
think that he at least said it which
makes us perhaps conclude that he's
right about banning here at least these
banning quotes are right at least been
and talked to him the the writer Michael
Wolfe says that he has tape of Bannon so
we'll have to see about that
but the Trump enos of all of it makes me
think that at least some of this is true
let's bring on the panel to describe it
we have flex talks Austin Fletcher and
we have Jacob berry guys what do you
think is this legitimate is Bannon done
flex what do you think I think it is I
was hoping that we would have heard
something from Bannon before everyone
started responding but once we got all
the responses from Don jr. and President
Trump himself it's kind of seems like
you know what said was said and you
can't really come back from it now it's
like when you kind of hold things in the
back of your mind when you have like
your girlfriend or a certain
relationship and then once you say them
you know those certain things that you
were holding in forever you can't really
take them back and it's never gonna be
the same so it's sad to see him go and
it's a shame to potentially lose
something like Breitbart a big ally of
the president hopefully you know he goes
two separate way from there and we don't
lose Breitbart if that's true and it is
pretty gross to think of Steve Bannon
and Donald Trump as boyfriend and
girlfriend up on and makeout point or
something in an old Cadillac but and
that's neither here nor there Jacob what
do you think I think I think van is
pretty much done if if he finds some way
to bounce back it's gonna be in Dick
Morris style you know where he just kind
of makes appearances on Newsmax TV I
think and gets caught doing weird things
with hookers in hotel rooms sure yeah
possibilities here sure but I honestly
think he's done I think that he he got
fired and he decided to get a little bit
of vengeance but it's really hard to get
vengeance on the President of the United
States especially when you don't know
anything so I honestly think that he's
had his time he had his moment in the
Sun and no one really even knew who he
was until this election the the
mainstream media kind of made ban in a
name so I think that when all this is
settled down when dust settles we'll be
going Bannon Bannon who absolutely I
don't know the guy personally but a
number of my
friends do some of them sort of like the
guy some of them say he's just a monster
so I really don't care about Steve
Bannon one thing also that makes this
seem kind of legit is that a apparently
Wolf's access ended way back right when
Bannon got kicked out of the White House
so it could have been that he was salty
about getting fired salty about how
things were going he gave these quotes
out and now they're dropping it's really
a matter of Liberty for me that's all I
care about in all of this is the freedom
of it all my freedom in particular so
Donald Trump has enacted a wonderfully
effective conservative agenda he's done
it pretty quickly within his first year
I like that I want more of that I want
lower taxes more tax reform less
regulation more originalist justices who
are going to respect the Constitution
more strength and credibility abroad I
don't really care who's doing it if
Steve Bannon is gonna help that great be
my guest go on and help it but if Steve
Bannon is gonna undermine this
presidency undermine this administration
because of some personal vendetta or
because he wants to burn down certain
aspects of the Republican Party sorry
buddy see you later
I don't know No thank you no no no more
give me the freedom give me the freedom
and if you're going to turn on that and
betray somebody and betray a movement
and betray your president your candidate
then you you're not going to be able to
do it it's like if these quotes are true
and they do seem fairly legitimate then
that big shoe of Donald Trump just came
down and squashed the guy you might be
trying to crawl out from under it but
it's it's no good we just have to keep
calm and make America great again okay
let's get to the news there so this is
sort of Trumpy news of the Virginia
House of Delegates now remains in
Republican hands because of a lottery in
a hat
David Yancey candidate there beat his
opponent Democrat Shelley Simons after
somebody pulled a name out of a hat it
was an exact tie there were multiple
recounts and so I guess in the Virginia
House of Delegates the way you resolve
that for the first time in the centuries
is you just reach into a hat and pull
out the Republican thankfully Jacob is
this race the ultimate demonstration of
the
error behind nevertrump behind well I'd
like Trump to win but I don't want to
vote for him because it's icky I don't
think so I honestly think that this was
just like you said it was just recount
after recount and I think the people
just wanted to see someone seated so
they brought in this old archaic rule
but as far as weather never Trumper have
anything to do this I don't think no
remember there's two types of never
Trump errs they're the we're gonna vote
for Hillary because we hate Trump for
some reason and then they're their David
French kind of Ben Shapiro and me
included in that who are just kind of
well we don't believe Trump is a
conservative and so far he has been his
first year I'll give him credit the most
conservative administration since at
least Reagan and possibly Coolidge well
I wouldn't go that far but I will say I
will say that we're still this
administration is still young so we
could see that lefty side that we know
existed in Trump at least for some time
but as far as this delegates situation
goes I think that they just wanted to in
this race and they're like let's just
get this over with so that we can seat
someone in this house I'm not gonna let
you off that easy
Jonah Goldberg said that he wanted Trump
to win that if the if the vote were a
perfect tie and it came down to him to
decide the winner he would have picked
Trump but nevertheless he will never
ever vote for Donald Trump because it's
icky because it would be hard to look at
himself in the mirror he's not good
enough for me he does something like
that right and his premise is that his
vote doesn't matter my vote doesn't
matter this election shows us even one
single vote can matter and not just in
that little House of Delegates election
but it throws the entire body with
without this guy winning the Republicans
would not control the Virginia House of
Delegates anymore so again though I'm
not sure what this really has to do with
with Trump as far I know you're trying
to connect it to college I'll explain to
you what it has to do with never Trump
never Trump errs were Republicans who
said I would like Trump to win generally
because it would be better than Hillary
Clinton but I don't want to actually
vote for him and it's okay because my
vote doesn't matter
what this shows is that your vote does
matter every single vote can matter
through a whole election uh you know I
don't think that was actually an ever
Trump argument I was your birthday that
may have been she was a leading never
Trump er well okay he was a big name
never Trump er I wouldn't say he like
was the face of the movement really I
would probably have to say that Glenn
Beck was probably the face of the never
Trump errs but I think that as far as
this goes remember I voted I didn't vote
for Trump or Hillary so yes I disagree I
think you should you should vote in
these situations and maybe Mickey Mouse
will win and maybe Mickey Mouse a win
but if for I know someone who hated
Trump but they voted for Trump because
they like pence and if that argument had
been presented to me hey if we will at
least get pence as the VP in a more
intellectual way I might have been more
persuaded with that argument but to me
this this Virginia House race just
represents just how how volatile the
elections have become in the era of
Trump and how important every single
vote is in the spirit of Republican
unity I will leave it there but I think
that conservatives and Republicans
should take a lesson from this election
and from the closeness of certain races
and the actual stakes for the country
rather than for how one looks in the
mirror flex is a random hat drawing the
best solution to a tied election besides
obviously recounting and recounting and
recounting yeah I don't think it's that
bad I think the Democrats should find a
way to make this the norm because 5050
odds take that I'll take that all day
that's the Democrats could do 5050 odds
with the whole thing and pull everyone's
name out of a hat I mean that blue wave
might happen so you're gonna get a lot
of dead people out of the Hat they've
been they've been trying versions of
this strategy for a fairly long time
absolutely right I also do kind of like
the whimsy of it of pulling the name out
of the Hat because so frequently one of
the negative sides of democratic
politics especially in an era where
politics and entertainment are exactly
the same thing is that people treat
politics like religion they treat it
like they're the the sole focus of their
life and that's what give their lives
meaning obviously we don't have a mom
ARC in America in countries with a
constitutional monarchy it's sort of the
monarchy that embodies the spirit of the
country and is the head of state and the
government kind of changes but there's
that stability and continuity in liberal
democracies like the United States we
don't really have that and so I do like
the idea of sometimes it's just gonna be
pulled out of a hat you're gonna roll
the dice that's your leader and it's
gonna be okay the government shouldn't
dictate every aspect of your life and if
it is doing that then you have to fix
something about your government more
importantly about your culture speaking
of the culture Jeff Sessions as Justice
Department is cutting an Obama era
dereliction of duty and finally
enforcing federal law on marijuana so
four years thought dispensaries have
cropped up all over California and other
states with legal marijuana even though
those state laws violate federal law now
flex you strike me as no stranger to the
OL Haitian oregano what should the
conservative position on pot
legalization be Michael my mother
watches this show
I'm sorry mrs. talks I'm kind of
disappointed because realistically I
think California was you know heading
towards this liberal utopia which is
also basically hell you know it's a
sanctuary state much of which is on fire
there's tons of homeless people many of
them have hepatitis it's not illegal to
give people AIDS knowingly anymore right
so I was kind of like every time I leave
my apartment I live downtown it's
basically a Mad Max movie so I'm kind of
disappointed that this final piece that
could have made you know gone all the
way around been California is officially
how I thought have been some good action
and made it more interesting so I'm a
little disappointed to see Jeff Sessions
tear these back a little bit that is too
bad yeah I really enjoy the
cinematography I'm driving around
downtown yeah all the explosions and
fumes
Jacob for a long time the libertarian
strain of conservatives and Republicans
have said we need to legalize pot
obviously all the lefties want to
legalize pot I personally don't really
have anything wrong with it I just don't
care that much except
the pro-pot people are so passionate
about it and they're so annoying that I
really want to make them upset so I want
pot to remain illegal I'm really torn on
this subject as you can see how should
conservatives think about it well I
think we should look at it honestly and
we should say okay when when we see now
I'm coming at it from a conservative
perspective not a libertarian
perspective but I think we should look
at the pros and cons of it one of the
it's not as volatile as even alcohol but
on the flip side there are people who
suffer dire consequences from being
addicted to it but also there's the
medical aspect of it now I don't believe
that marijuana cures cancer I've not
seen I've seen nothing but very
subjective gossip that it that it has
any effect on cancer on cancerous cells
but I do think that people who suffer
with chronic pain who are who suffer
with anxiety maybe it can be medically
applied to them now it's be clear though
I'm against of all forms of smoking when
you have a grandmother who had a lung
transplant it kind of takes the wind out
of your cells as far as smoking itself
goes but I think if we're very Pro
brownie I'm out I'm very Pro Brown yes
absolutely like I said we can always
look at the medical aspect of it but I'm
I kind of agree with you that about the
the pro pot people they just get so
insanely crazy you just want to go oh
man just be quiet it also I will say I
won't tell any tales at a school I might
have tried the old Haitian oregano once
or twice I had a local yogurt when I was
in India and it turns out that local
yogurt was a very mystical indeed here
we were on the ganges and i just can't
get that into it I just don't really
like it that much so as a matter of
culture I don't really want to encourage
people to do it it's it's not really
that fun I find people say it makes you
so much funnier that isn't true it you
just think things are funnier because
you get stupider and hungrier and fatter
but you aren't funnier so I don't like
that aspect of it it just makes you kind
of confused and your heart beats a
little faster I can't get that into it
at all I would come to a compromise that
we can legalize pot if we first
legalized Cuban cigars I'm
very hopeful I would support that yeah
sure that's that's see that's the spirit
of compromise we're getting things done
the art of the deal gentlemen we got to
move on to the mailbag but thank you for
being here
Austin Fletcher flex talks once again
missus talks I'm very sorry I'm only
joking and Jakob berry from The Daily
wire thank you both I will talk to you
soon look I know you want to hear the
mailbag we have some really good
questions we have some video answers but
if you are not subscribed to the daily
wire.com we just can't do it folks I'm
sorry I want you to stick around if
you're on Facebook and YouTube we got to
say goodbye if you already subscribe
thank you you helped keep the lights on
you keep qoph fa in my cup we really
appreciate it if you don't subscribe
guys come on it's the new year it's the
Trump economy 4% economic growth
massive tax cuts if you have an S corp
you're about to make a ton of more money
it's ten bucks a month or $100 for an
annual membership what do you get you
get me you get the indra Clavin show you
get the Ben Shapiro show no ads on the
website but you get this the leftist
here's tumblr and I will say I had a
knock-down drag-out debate with the
Daily wires director of tumblers because
as you'll notice I don't use the the lid
on the show I drink it without the lid
like a civilized person who's not
driving a car but I have to tell you all
of the lawyers want me to say it comes
with a lid so if you if you get it today
you'll get a special limited edition
Michael Noel's show leftist here's
tumbler with a detachable lid so you can
use the lid you can take the lid off
we're all about freedom of choice here
on the right and in the conservative and
Liberty movement so go over to the daily
wired.com right now we'll be right back
[Music]
first question comes from Aleutian
question is what is the UN John take it
away the point that I want to leave with
you in this very brief presentation is
where I started is there is no United
Nations there is an international
community that occasionally can be led
by the only real power left in the world
and that's the United States when it
suits our interest and when we can get
others to go along Secretariat building
in New York has 38 stories if you lost
10 stories today it would make a bit of
difference this kind of mindless
creation of the United Nations as
something different than what it's in
the United States interest to do isn't
going to sell here or anywhere else the
United States makes the UN work when it
wants it to work and that is exactly the
way it should be because the only
question the only question for the
United States is what's in our national
interest and if you don't like that I'm
sorry but that is the fact you said it
brother you said that is former UN
Ambassador John Bolton I couldn't have
said it any better
next question from Jason hi Michael I
work in tech and never learned much
history what books would you recommend
for learning about the history of
Western civilization I'm trying to avoid
the revisionist trash but don't know
where to start
PS your book is inexplicably good Jason
thank you Jason you clearly have great
taste in literature so I always
recommend this book whenever anyone says
I don't know anything about the history
of Western civilization I want a kind of
recent book to sum things up for me you
can start with the modern era that's
from about 1500 to 2000 through the
present the era that begins with what we
would call the Renaissance or the High
Middle Ages the best book on that to
begin I think is from dawn to decadence
by Jacque Morrison he's the guy who
started great books at Columbia one of
the reasons this book is so good is
he'll just include in parentheses other
books you should read as he goes through
everything from the Protestant
revolution all the way up through the
present it's a really good work on
modern Western
story it explains how we got from the
advent of Protestantism all the way
through the present just about
everywhere on earth so it's really
really good you should also read maybe
the greatest history book ever written
through Siddha T's you might notice I
borrowed a line from Thucydides to open
up my own magnum opus reasons to vote
for Democrats a comprehensive guide that
that's a great ancient history work and
really the beginning of I think where
you should start on ancient history if
you want other things that are kind of
in the news people are always attacking
Christopher Columbus or was attacking
the Pilgrims and the founding of America
some good books to start on that that
you can breeze through in a day or two
maybe two or three days as Samuel Eliot
Morrison's book on Christopher Columbus
Admiral of the ocean sea is really good
he's not a lefty lunatic he's a little
bit more conservative historian but a
wonderful highly respected historian and
a Nathaniel Philbrick is pretty
even-handed in his treatment of the
pilgrims in the Mayflower this was a
very popular American history book that
came out maybe ten years ago start with
those dawn to decadence is where I would
begin and then you can get more into
what I think is really fascinating
history in the Middle Ages and late Rome
but I would begin there and you kind of
work your way backwards from what you
know to from what is familiar all the
way backward into the foundations of
your civilization in your culture from
Garrett hi Michael I would like you to
bring light to my confusion with CS
Lewis's law of human nature
Louis states that there are typically
two instincts that humans face when
looking at a problem the right instinct
in the wrong instinct and there's a
third there's there's a conscience so
this argument tends to work for most
people
but it doesn't work for all for example
a child who is out of control does what
they want to do without regard for a
conscience the typical response for this
predicament as the child is not yet
learned right from wrong
but the moral law that Louis is
proposing is saying that right from
wrong is built into us I do not know if
humans would not would know not to steal
murder or line naturally can you please
clear this up for me thanks yes
absolutely they would know this
naturally this these moral laws have
been observed in all people at all times
in all places now Louis writes is
specifically addresses this he says this
law was called the law
nature because people thought that
everyone knew it by nature and did not
need to be taught it they did not mean
of course that you might not find an odd
individual here or there who did not
know it just as you find a few people
who are colorblind or who have no ear
for a tune but taking the race as a
whole they thought that the human idea
of decent behavior was obvious to
everyone so yeah there's gonna be a
random psychopath or someone who has no
moral sense but these are exceptions
that prove rules when it comes to the
specific example of little children a
three-year-old is the worst individual
on the face of the earth right the
three-year-olds are just awful monsters
of selfishness who demand everything and
don't really care about anybody else but
this is because they haven't yet reached
the age of reason so the age of reason
the Catholic Church says the age of
reason occurs around seven years old but
just about every framework for viewing
the world has some sense of the age of
reason three-year-olds are not
reasonable in the way that older
children and then teenagers and adults
are reasonable so a way to think of it
is that my ability to reproduce is
built-in to me it is a fact of nature it
isn't something I learn I didn't learn
how to reproduce trust me if I were in
the woods I would do it just fine and
people all over the world have done but
I can't produce sperm cells at age four
either I haven't yet reached an age of
maturity there was a time to every
purpose under heaven
and so well that law of nature has built
into all of us we must mature even Jesus
and the Gospels grows in wisdom right he
growth he matures because he's in time
and space and he's in fleshed in a body
so far from contradicting this law of
nature it simply tells us something
about our own time and our own space and
what we have to do to to live as human
beings with with bodies as well from
Alex hey Michael I have a bit of a
dilemma I'm very attracted to the idea
of the Catholic Church you know I'm
always shocked when we get these
Catholic questions we never get these do
we Marshall never get that some minutes
wonder if I'm very pleased in any case I
recognize that if there were to be a one
true church the Catholic Church would be
the best candidate to hold that mantle
however I'm a former member of the LDS
Church the Mormon Church that got very
thoroughly burned by my whole world
become
unravelled what advice would you give to
someone who loves God is currently
active in an evangelical church and
would like to know how best to worship
Him thanks Alex
well I'm glad to hear that you've found
an evangelical church that is bringing
you closer to God and that you're in and
that you're also thinking about joining
the Catholic Church and you're thinking
that might be the next step that is a
little bit retelling of my own return to
the Catholic Church I did read a lot of
Protestant theologians and evangelical
writers and preachers on my way back
across the Tiber to - or my Pope ish
2,000 year old institution one of the
you bring this up with the LDS Church
this is the risk of dealing in real
institutions and it's the end it's a
real risk of faulty teaching and faulty
engagement with the faith this isn't
just about LDS or some other derivative
of Christianity even Catholic schooling
I have a lot of people who come up to me
they say Michael you're still in the
Catholic Church did you go to Catholic
school and I'll say no and they said oh
that's why you're still in the Catholic
Church I know a lot of people who went
to Catholic schooling and they just led
them they ran away they they had bad
experiences they don't want to associate
with their childhood in the pain that
comes with being a child or an
adolescent so that this is a trouble the
thing that you must do is not throw the
baby out with the bathwater something
that might aid you on your journey
there's a wonderful resource called
Catholic Answers which is the benefit of
being around for 2,000 years and having
people during those two millennia
debating all of these questions is if
you opposed to the Catholic Church what
should I have for breakfast on Tuesday
morning at 8:00 they'll have an answer
they'll say bacon and eggs and you know
orange juice or something so you you can
consult a lot of the questions you might
have on the institution of the church on
the sacraments on the Magisterium on the
church fathers whatever you can search
for it and you'll probably find an
answer if you're drawn to the notion
that the God who became incarnate and
and fleshed and lived for a certain time
in a real time in place chose real
people to do real things who instituted
the Acts of the Apostles and who said
Peter on this rock I build my church
feed my sheep you have the keys to the
kingdom
of heaven whatever you loose on earth
will be loosed in heaven whatever you
bind on earth will be bound in heaven if
you if that leads you to conclude that
maybe there is a real church with a real
order real people running it then I
encourage you in that and don't be
discouraged the devil likes to
discourage us that's his main tool is to
say no no cynicism you know that no no
it's all fake people are all fools and
don't ever commit yourself to something
real that will make you vulnerable
don't don't fall into that trap proceed
in joy and and seriousness you know and
with joy and prudence and I wish you
luck on your journey from Preston hey
Michael I'm 20 years old and I reside in
Chattanooga Tennessee
I just recently received a premium
subscription to The Daily wire well
congratulations I mean you're gonna
survive the floods that's really good
pal I'm going to see you on the ark and
the ark that'll just be it'll just be
people floating on left us cheers
tumblers I couldn't have asked for a
better gift I am having trouble finding
a major that suits me a major in college
I assume I enjoy theology and politics
any suggestions yes I don't necessarily
recommend studying either of those
undergraduate theology might be good to
study I don't recommend political
science really any of the social
sciences I prefer disciplines that are
older that are more grounded in the
university the social sciences came
about relatively recently they came
about as theories to apply the
scientific method to things that don't
necessarily lend themselves to the
scientific method such as human affairs
government history
I majored in history that was one of my
majors in college I recommend that
history will give you a grounding for
anything that you want to do it will
give you in my view a better political
education than a political science ever
would political philosophy is an
interesting field of study but it's
fallen totally out of favor at the
University in favor of political science
which I don't have a ton of respect for
I would study that if you if you're
interested in politics and theology I
might study the classics I might study
literature I think literature is a
wonderful way to engage in both theology
and politics literature basically
converted Andrew Clavin to Christianity
literature and Christmas cookie
so that's one recommendation for it but
in an older field of study and older
discipline I think will serve you well
in any of your interests from Jessica
dear Michael how do you know how the new
tax plan will affect freelance musicians
Thank You Jessica well as a former
freelance actor myself you'll probably
be fine because freelance artists don't
make any money in mine in my own humble
experience of it it actually will help
you a lot I think because of the
advantages to pass-through entities so a
lot of freelance artists have an
s-corporation
they'll incorporate themselves so an
actor could incorporate himself and then
deduct movie tickets wardrobe haircuts
whatever you can deduct things that feed
into the business of that if you're a
blank book writer like me then you could
deduct blank sheets of paper or pens
without any ink in them those could be
business deductions as well under the
new tax plan you can deduct I think up
to 25 percent of your income so that is
a real nice benefit if you're an artist
I assume you live in one of these
godforsaken cities with high city and
state and local taxation like Los
Angeles or New York that part will ding
you a little bit but I think it'll be
more than made up for on the S corpse if
you haven't incorporated yourself as an
artist and you do make an income
incorporate yourself there are a lot of
benefits to it from Nathan
Michael Noel's king of the trolls what
is your favorite color Nathan my
favorite color is green there's no joke
there's no any addition to that I just
really like the color green green like
money I guess from Marcus hi Michael I
love your show my question when should
we hit a bully back twice as hard and
when should we turn the other cheek
please answer using biblical references
people misunderstand this all the time
a lot of people who would just take
Christianity to be just some small
aspect of it they'll become pacifists
they'll say we should never punch back
don't ever fight back they've only read
a couple lines of the Bible and they'll
say see it says this they haven't read
the other things GK Chesterton wrote
northa doxy that heresy is not the
promotion of Vice it's just a promotion
of one virtue to the exclusion of all
the others that's what they're getting
at but don't forget to classy ass tees
there is a time for everything and a
season for every purpose under
heaven there's a time for war and a time
for peace in the same breath that Christ
says turn the other cheek
he also says if your right eye causes
you to sin pluck it out and throw it
away
I don't know that he means that
literally if your right hand causes you
to sin cut it off and throw it away I
don't know that he means that literally
as we mean literally he says do not say
anything other than yes or no everything
else that you say comes to evil of
course he doesn't mean that literally
cuz he says many other things and he
tells st. Paul takes many oaths it takes
many vows he says only pray in your
inner closet but then Christ praise in
public as well so Christ also says to
the Apostles if you don't have a sword
sell your cloak and buy one he says that
very explicitly st. Agustin and st.
Thomas Aquinas both explained just war
very well all the reasons when wars can
legitimately be undertaken Santa Claus
himself st. Nicholas punched a heretic
in the face at the first Council of
Nicaea when we're talking about that
Sermon on the Mount Christ sums up the
whole sermon in the next chapter he says
seek first his kingdom and his
righteousness and all these things shall
be yours as well that's what he's
telling us seek first the kingdom of God
then follow everything else and then he
gives us these examples these parabolic
examples these hyperbolic examples do
not you shouldn't strike back at
somebody for spite or for cruelty or
even really for vengeance so I don't
think that you should be doing it say ah
that'll hurt him and that will give me
great pleasure and joy but our Lord is
also not telling us to be doormats and
to let the cruel rape the face of the
earth Christ is speaking of a spiritual
strategy to Humble the self and to win
other souls over to him but not
everybody has moved necessarily by this
humility so we should love our neighbors
as ourselves but sometimes we all need a
little bit of tough love don't we a
priest friend of mine keeps a baseball
bat near the door of his rectory because
it's not a great neighborhood there have
been break-ins and burglaries of the
poor box I one time asked him about this
and he explained it to me sometimes
there just isn't time to turn the other
cheek
that's my feeling as well that's our
whole show for today
be sure to tune in to another kingdom
it's finally back my podcast with Andrew
Klavan
the
next chapter is up chapter 11 episode 11
and we're coming to a big climax in this
if you haven't caught up listen it's a
really fun narrative podcast that is
going to go up tomorrow morning
tune in on Monday we'll be back to do it
all over again I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Nolt show we'll see you
then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer
Mathis Glover our technical producer is
austin stevens edited by alex is and
Garo audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina
hair and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knoll show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2017